Time magazine celebrated its one hundred
most POW influential people with a gala
in New York City under honoring dozens
of leaders across many industries the
time 100 party brought some of the
world's most influential people all
under one roof
this year's list includes artists
athletes icons and pioneers in their
fields and our own Gayle King made the
list for the first time I just believe
in dreaming big and I never even dreamed
this big and I'm standing here on the
time 100 carpet to get this award is
just something that I never even dreamed
of I always want to influence people for
the better and I always want to make
people smile and make people happy so
the fact that people are like okay
you're doing exactly that right now it's
just really awesome big smiles there and
we should point out that almost half of
those honored this year are women yeah
they said that's the most ever yeah and
Gayle we want to let you know we spoke
to some people on the red carpet last
night who wanted to share their messages
with you so take a listen she's so
awesome she's so strong when I first met
you I was like oh man she's so lucky
because she has Oprah as a friend and
now getting to know me I'm like oh no
Oprah's lucky to have a Gayle in her
life we all should have a Gayle so
congrats on everything Gayle way to go
Gayle you're killing it girl I'm very
very proud of you and we kind of share
these covers which is cool watch this
she is she's a star Gayle is one of the
kindest people in the world she's also
kind of the heart and soul of our show
Gayle will sometimes say the thing that
is on her mind and that needs to be said
and then perhaps others wouldn't say and
there's a kind of wonderful candor about
Gayle I was even having trouble being
candid about that
so a man came up to me yesterday he said
you know what sometimes you say things I
don't even know that I'm thinking very
funny way to say it but I have to say a
special shout-out to the CBS
photographer I think it was Darrell last
night it was Terrence on the red carpet
last night because I had these hot
flashes there's no good time to have it
but I started sweating like a Brahma
bull and he said you might want to stop
for a second and you know wipe yourself
off there's no good time but it looks
like I'm having an illness of some kind
I really appreciate him calling cuz
you're walking down that thing
but I have to tell you guys it was so
much fun Nora and John we've been going
to these things for a very long time and
I've always liked just being as I've
said being a looky-loo in the room
because there's always somebody you want
to meet some young I talk to so it was
really a kick Glenn Close and I were
sort of pinching each other can you
believe we're on the list this year that
is really how it felt to me that was fun
for us to to collect compliments does
take a village it really does what we do
here is a huge huge team effort and I'm
forever grateful for everybody that we
work with in this room